hey bubs I'm Greg and I'm John so we
just saw x-men apocalypse let me tell
you hands-down the best movie out of the
MCU Kevin Figgy and the team has really
put together
I'm kidding just kind of piss off the
world right now I like this movie I want
to put that outside I really liked it I
thought it was very enjoyable you know
it's not better than Days of Future past
or x-men first class in my opinion I
still really liked the characters I
loved a lot like there was a lot of
scenes that I genuinely loved a lot of
people are saying this like the first
half is better than the last half
looking back on the film I do agree with
that I think the first half is more
solid well I feel like the first half
had a lot more breathing room and it
treated as characters a lot more
naturally and then partway through the
movie you get the sense that they just
kind of had to hurry up because scenes
would get shorter and they would get a
lot more blocky in the dialogue and a
lot more sort of like we have to go here
now like they set the characters up
really great and then some of the
payoffs are the right ones but they just
kind of come together quick what I gotta
say that I really liked about the last
half was in the first half it's kind
back and forth looking a lot of
different characters a lot of different
storylines and then sometimes you spend
a lot of time with one character and
then it cuts back to like you know
mystique for example and you're like oh
[ __ ] that's right that's right there's a
whole storyline here with misty at first
it's like I'm enjoying the storylines
but I kind of forget about some
storylines
even though I'm enjoying them by the end
they all do come together really well
I feel like all the storylines do get
complete which is you know a thing that
tends to not happen in films like this
where there's so many characters but yet
I felt like everyone's story pretty much
got rhabdo actually I think this movie
kind of plays out like a really cool
graphic novel and I do think that it
handles it's ensemble pretty what isn't
the best ensemble piece I've seen but
it's certainly not the worst one and
everybody does get a chance to shine
even the performances I wasn't as high
on everybody got a moment Raw's like
that's awesome and in terms of like tone
to I didn't feel like this was an x-men
movie on a repeat tone what I liked
about the last few installments is that
they've all been a different tone
for the most part from first class to
the Wolverines Days of Future past now
this
it's called x-men apocalypse and I was
like yeah this does have kind of a cool
different kind of apocalyptic vibe to it
especially when you see apocalypsis
power just really grow then yeah and
become more powerful
I like how apocalypse you know doesn't
like what mankind's become but yet he
knows how to use mankind you know
development of technologies to use in
his favor to work against them that's
been a very popular thing for comic-book
movies right now is to have that sort of
like ah humanity I'm going to evolve the
world and you have godlike place I like
how they did that with this I like a
sort of arcane and the sort of biblical
proportions that they introduced
apocalypse with and all that you know
and it's a cool vibe to bring it we've
come a long way since x-men 1 and 2 the
tone is different but it doesn't feel
like every other Marvel movie which I'm
happy about cuz yeah part of it in the
beginning I felt a lot of love for
Indiana Jones well yeah I thought of the
mummy yeah exactly stuff like those like
adventure and there was sort of an
archaeological with all the production
design there is just a lot of cool
design [ __ ] in this totally to you at
the end of the day like is some of the
pacing off yes is some of is the
structure a little later on yeah like
some stuff it doesn't quite hit there's
there's definite flaws in there this
movie like it really comes down to do I
like the characters and did I enjoy like
being on an adventure with them
absolutely Charles Xavier James McAvoy I
really like what he does every time with
Charles Xavier I like what you did here
I know you had some gripes well it's not
it's not a gripe cuz I still enjoyed it
is the thing but I feel like there are
some moments of humor and some self
conscious moments that to me felt like
they may have been shoehorned in because
of all the like oh we're too grim it's
weird there's some like comedy lines and
like it sound like comedy lines that
were forced in there yet I steer story
yeah this is out of place but I still
think it's cool like like the first
sentence magneto says to apocalypse was
like a character but I'm like still
laugh though and he has some stuff some
repeat again like the same same
philosophical cost between Xavier and
then Xavier seeing Raven yeah whoa just
like it's not the deepest of these I
like that they did attempt to you know
at least make it somewhat allegorical
what you know socially relevant I get
the complaint about like it's always
kind of Magneto Professor Xavier going
back and forth like his magneto gonna be
alright this time we'll probably not but
huh maybe he'll come back with AC it
would be a major problem for me if
magneto was the main villain again I'd
like that but like but he's a follower
he's following apocalypse in this one I
like that he became almost like a
general I do like magneto storyline like
Eric's story line in the movie
especially in the first half like
setting up of life he had before
apocalypse came in and then how a
vocalist was changing his life it's very
different than anything we've seen of
Erik I thought Michael Fassbender had a
fantastic scene in there yeah they're
all alike damn it really still cares
about the rule they took a character
motivation that's very popular right now
and is easy to make trite and they made
me care about it they put some real you
know kind of human emotion under it and
Jennifer Lawrence's mystique when I saw
the trailer I was like yeah kind of
looks like The Hunger Games game like
there's more than I thought I did I
wasn't distracted by the fact that it
was Jennifer Lawrence if anything the
only times I got distracted was when she
was actually blue and she looked like
just Jennifer Lawrence I wasn't pulled
out but whenever she did look in the
blue makeup I couldn't help but be aware
that's Jennifer Lawrence in the mystique
makeup yeah yeah oh what Nicholas Hoult
was as beast he was back I thought he
was fine I think he's got some nice
moments but he was a little lost here
yeah I gotta say this about Nicholas
Hoult that he does a good job he
delivers on what the role requires but
he's never been as intriguing as Kelsey
Grammer I know it's like two very I
don't think that goes well does a bad
job by any stretch I just don't think
that he got very interesting scenes in
this movie because I liked him a lot
more in like first class and I feel like
we got to know him or like they hinted
him being kind of like all upset over a
mystique and that doesn't really get
time to germinate and Oscar Isaac is
apocalypse I thought I did a really good
job you know some people get a lane
about the size of him I like the scenes
where he's gathering his four horsemen
sure in terms of physicality he ain't
exactly the most intimidating looking uh
front but the movie makes it really
clear the powers he has I don't need to
see some guy who's huge when I know what
he's [ __ ] capable of doing that did a
pretty good job of that there were times
when I was wondering like if you have
such and such powers why aren't you just
destroying everything
why aren't you
acting a little more right now and that
might be in the plot it says it was a
little hard for me to grab I thought
Oscar Isaac did a good job acting
through that make up part of the thing
with with most of these superhero movies
is it always takes me a little time to
reveal out which ones I'm gonna find
memorable and which ones I don't know
yeah we got a lot of films on the MCU
and I think this is like where I'm
sitting right I know this is not the
same thing but you know yeah I mean he
has some cool kills in the film which I
like to I mean there's some like cliche
stuff that happens with him you know
like there's this one scene where you
learned everything about the world
through like that they always have like
whatever they have that all-powerful
characters let me check into the nearest
Technology just once and I will know all
of history
this dude is definitely evil yeah well I
saw that apocalypse didn't view himself
as evil well and he I liked that they
gave him a certain like hubris like it
wasn't just I'm doing the race yeah he's
like I am your God you should be
worshipping he takes the mutants like I
am your father
yeah like he he seems like he like if
you're a mute and it sounds like he's
gonna care about you you know yeah yeah
or you know at least if you're along
with his you know agenda one of my
favorite parts of this movie was Evan
Peters I mean I think he's you said at
first I mean he steals the show pretty
much any timing on the screen doesn't
get like a [ __ ] ton of lines but
everything in his body language his
facial expressions and the few lines he
gets he embodies it he is a scene
stealer whenever he's in front of the
camera yeah he may want his powers mean
[ __ ] cool like he makes it count and
he's some of the humor that feels very
natural yeah in this movie and and he
has one of the coolest action sequences
in the whole movie they do that thing
that we loved in Days of Future past
where you know everything slowed down
and it's taking control but I'm not
gonna tell you exactly how they did it
yeah but they do manage to take it to a
bigger level and you're like yep that
was pretty sweet and good choice of
music food I kind of like the girl who
played storm I like the girl place I
liked what they did I liked what they
did with her I got distracted by her
accent a couple times I think the girl
who played you know what we always
distracting so the ArcLight has a little
like hey what a lot of people work on
this film was presented by the girl
played storm and she's American then you
watch him right in your life that's why
I should put another next yeah I like
storm in the film
she was way more interesting than any of
the other storm interpretations God or
any more than alle the way more
interesting character and I like how
they took the approach of but when storm
you know start talking like in this
villain origin story yeah and I thought
that was really cool a lot of people
seem to really like sophie Turner as
Jean Grey I
she had just that serious thing that a
lot of these movies have she had a
couple scenes that I that I did like her
more in like she had a couple moments
where she does shine to me for most of
the movie and the way they handle her
character and her powers didn't seem to
have as much life to me a lot of the
other people that's true Tye Sheridan I
thought they improved like I thought the
improve the writing of Cyclops more yeah
yeah however this guy sometimes seemed a
little melodramatic sometimes I mean
showing you know personality charm it
seemed a little left-field I feel like I
might like him more later like I feel
like again it's sort of like this scenes
he got were certain kinds of scenes I
thought he was alright like I wasn't in
love with his interpretation but I
didn't think of bad either
yeah and I felt like they could have had
a bigger payoff with him becoming you
know Cyclops by the end they do set him
up like aha I'm a really disturbing you
don't like myself and then what kind of
just cooled everything that's the thing
that's the kind of troublesome thing
about this movies it's it has so many
strong set ups and then by the end there
are certain characters who get wrapped
up or who get brought to the end kind of
abruptly so you're like wait a minute I
get it like it it doesn't wreck the
movie for me but it does start to weigh
things down later Kodi smit-mcphee as
Nightcrawler I thought was great I liked
his introduction I thought he had a lot
more Lanikai reminding me a Michael
Jackson yeah a little bit I mean cuz
it's the 80s too so they took advantage
of that a few times and in ways no I
liked everything they did with him I
thought he had a cool opening fight
scene too you know with uh yeah Joel
that was the kind of fanservice I really
liked his one night when he finds like a
badass yeah like an angel I thought was
cool too it has you seen the trailer she
becomes arc angel at one point the
transformation scene out of all the
angel scenes might mean that this is
more heat transfer from angel to
Archangel that was a very memorable like
a sex moment for me like it made me
cringe a little bit and that's some of
the stuff I like a lot about this movie
is that there are certain things that
happen that are bull
you know that they ought to stand out of
these movies that's kind of another
heavy load on this movie for me as the
CG cuz some of it looks great and some
of it does not look great
well the problem is because in the last
half of the movie you know when it gets
to the trailer you know the baby bug
yeah that lazy or like everything is see
Gina you're like like the whole
background most of it is now CG and then
like you see behind the scenes stuff
after the movie and before the movie
yeah Arika light and you're like wow
like the whole blending is practically
all CG like and they didn't shoot on
location and then throw in CG like
everything is CG they picked and chose
and they chose the right moments to make
look fantastic they are like the money
estuve money shots but there are a
number of other CG sequences and
green-screen sequences work at least for
me I could really tell yeah yeah there's
some stuff that looks unfinished in a
way that's almost refreshing to me just
cuz it's like oh it's real and Olivia
Munn as psylocke I thought I thought she
was good I like what she brought to it
they didn't do a ton with that character
so yeah but I wish she could have been
very conventional she could have been
very cliche and I know the end of it I
would like I liked her I didn't yeah and
I know her more as a host and things
like that than I do as an actress and so
that was cool to see like man I really
like what she's doing here yeah I like
how apocalypse hooks up all his four
horsemen with him like really cool suits
and and one scene they actually show him
like adjusting like alright he's a
designer he's got this like I give style
off like the [ __ ] of yeah you're the
one who doesn't look like you're just
gonna wear a one-piece man yeah the
trailers you know they they do give a
way that there's a character that
appears I'm just gonna say it's already
in the trailers Wolverine not gonna say
what the scene is pretty [ __ ] cool
though it's pretty [ __ ] cool and you
know some people complain that he wasn't
in it enough oh no no I thought he was I
thought it was don't cuz that was like a
great
cameo that's also a thing is like there
are certain things I think that are
really cool about this movie that do go
on a little the Wolverine scene is just
right well and it does show a different
side of
yeah which which I appreciated too
wasn't just like Wolverine seen some
like badass sarcastic line or something
yeah like there's there's some stuff
we're gonna see a new cyber yeah yeah I
mean overall like this films jam-packed
with characters but I I felt like it
handled its its load really well and I
thought it was a very enjoyable film I
think it's a really good addition to
this franchise I think it's one of those
films that beyond fanservice to comics
it's also fanservice to people who just
have been on board for these movies all
these years yeah and because there's
certain hints and certain like repeat
dialogue from previous x-men movies you
know it's like they're paint Amash to
that they get a little meta here and
there so that was there are certain
times when they wink at the camera and
again I was like I enjoyed this but also
it feels a little out of place but I
definitely wouldn't skip it or skip
through it like if oh yeah marathon like
like origins I tried marathoning
an x-men and I just I had to like skip
through it yeah so bad even if it's not
the best made of all the superhero
movies out it's kind of in the middle
it still has certain things that are fun
and fanciful that I'm like oh cool I get
it you still got creative here it was
acting like just maybe as an overall
movie it's not one of the best yeah but
there are some scenes in here
that are definitely not in other [ __ ]
comic yeah yeah there's some really good
stuff I give it a 15 mind reading
genitals and I give it a negasonic
teenage warhead subscribe to the real
rejects reasons to Jerry yeah blue mouse
calm we're on social media probably has
the kind of 80 minutes of this review
because we talked for way too long and
we have a Community Guidelines right
from a podcast we did in 2012